so often happens at the end of the term
we have a flurry of proposal defenses
and defenses and so today we have a
proposal defense from Ravi Madera who is
a student in the BC B track in the
master's program and his Advisory
Committee over here
dr. Cohen dr. Barrett and dr. Phil warm
Walmart and Robby received a honours
baccalaureate degree in biochemistry and
biophysics from Oregon State he had a
few jobs around the campus and primate
Center doing bench research in molecular
biology then he came over to the dry
side and joined our program and he's in
the BCB track he's also an avid sports
fan and enjoys playing cricket maybe
he'll teach us someday but what he'll do
today is give us his proposal and we
will question him this isn't like the
formal defense where we the audience has
to leave and so forth although his
committee may want to ask him questions
afterwards so
thank you everyone for coming today can
everyone hear me
today I will be presenting my thesis
proposal on improving protein
identification and quantification in
shotgun proteomics by clustering so let
me begin with a defining proteome the
term proteome is coined in the 1990s to
mimic the term genome which represents
an entire collection of genes in a
system so a proteome is a set of
proteins expressed or modified by cell
lines tissues organisms or any
biological system and similar to
genomics and proteomics is traditionally
defined as the large-scale
characterization of the entire protein
however with the improvements in the
proteomics field a more inclusive
definition also exists which is to
understand the biological functions such
as protein expression levels post
translational modifications and
regulation of proteins protein protein
interactions and characterization of
protein complexes beginning in the 1990s
mass spectrometry has become the the
predominant tool for protein
identification and characterization and
when mass spec was originally mass spec
was originally restricted for small or
thermostable compounds because of lack
of ionization techniques that can i
anice molecules from a condensed phase
to a gas phase but with the addition of
MALDI and ESI electron spray ionization
mass spec analysis was accessible for a
large polypeptides and these ionization
methods in conjunction with high
performance liquid chromatography or
HPLC allowed highly automated Studies on
biological samples and there are also
improvements in mass and mass analyzers
such as time-of-flight quadrupole
time-of-flight ion trap orbit trap
instruments that drastically improve the
sensitivity and the accuracy of protein
and peptide detection and these
instruments now allow us to obtain
peptide sequences peptide abundances and
also post translational States and
samples with thousands of proteins can
be now routinely processed and finally
the like all large-scale high-throughput
methodologies there are improvements in
computational tools such as bio
analytics and bioinformatics that have
gone hand-in-hand with platform
development and so these advances have
allowed proteomics to move beyond
protein identification and
quantification and to a more advanced
studies of functional and structural
proteomics in complex biological systems
there are two processing methods in
proteomics you have the top-down
processing or sorry top-down proteomics
and watch more proteomics in top-down
proteomics and and a protein usually an
intact protein of about 200 kilo daltons
is characterized using liquid
chromatography or mass mass spectrometry
or tandem mass spectrometry and in
top-down processing it usually requires
an extensive protein purifications to
get good characterization of the
proteins however the most widely used
processing method is the bottom-up
proteomics this is where proteins are
first digested into peptides
using enzymes such as a trypsin or
chymotrypsin and then the peptide
mixture is then subjected to liquid
chromatography or mass spec for peptide
characterization and when bottom-up
analysis is performed on a mixture of
proteins it is called shotgun proteomics
in the ideas very similar to the idea of
shortman sequencing of DNA so let me
walk you through a typical shotgun
proteomics experiment I can the
experiment can be split into three steps
the first step is sample preparation and
peptide separation so in the first step
of a sample is first digest into
peptides like I said using enzymes like
let's not cry more trypsin and
optionally these peptide mixtures can be
processed to capture a specific type of
especially class of peptides like
phosphorylated or glycosylated peptides
and then these peptides are then
separated using the liquid
chromatography system the second step
involves peptide sequencing with mass
spectrometry and these peptides as they
load from liquid chromatography are then
ionized using electron spray and they're
transferred into a gaseous phase and
then the selected ions are then
subjected to a liquid or a mass
spectrometry and the result of mass
spectrometry is the production of these
ions fragmented ion spectra that can be
associated with peptide sequences and
the final step is peptide identification
this is where the spectra that's
obtained from the tandem mass
spectrometry is compared to a
theoretical spectrum that is predicted
from in silico digestion of protein
sequence databases so let's take a
closer look into a step three now the
protein search database that usually
contains a large number of proteins such
as ncbi or uniprot it undergoes an in
silico enzymatic digestion to generate
all possible peptides in the sample and
based on the measured mass of the
peptide ion you can obtain a
fragmentation models of similar
theoretical peptides and these are the
the theoretical spectrum and then on the
other hand what happens is to the
acquired spectrum it's first filtered
for noise and then normalized before
being scored against the the theoretical
spectrum using search engines such as
Seacrest or mascot and these search
engines they use some a proprietary
scoring function to rank the peptide to
spectral matches or PSMs
and as you can see from this figure
they've identified five candidate
peptides that can match to this acquired
spectrum and there's a score given next
to each peptide and generally the
highest scoring peptide is
identified as the peptide match for the
spectrum so when proteins are chopped
into smaller pieces by trypsin or other
enzymes there can be a loss of
connectivity between proteins and
peptides and despite all the
advancements and mass back
instrumentation there is still a
difficulty in inferring proteins from
the observed peptides and the digested
peptides can fall into two categories
you can have unique peptides which
provide immediate information about
their parent proteins so for an example
in this figure you have peptides 4 & 5
which are only a link to protein 4 so
they only have information about working
for so from this example if you see
peptides 4 & 5 you immediately know that
protein 4 exists in the sample and on
the other hand you can also have shared
or degenerate peptides these peptides
can be linked to multiple proteins so
they provide this confounding protein
information so for instance in this
figure again you know if you see prep
Ed's 1 & 2 they can be present in both
proteins 1 & 2 so you don't know if
protein 1 or 2 or both proteins to exist
in the sample so this sort of challenge
in proteomics is very similar to that in
next-generation sequencing where short
DNA reads have to be mapped to their
originating genes so the last part of
shotgun proteomics is the protein
inference step and this is where you
want to identify all the proteins from
the observed peptides and unlike DNA
there is a you cannot really amplify
proteins and also despite the the
reduced information content that you get
from shared peptides you can't ignore
them because you could lose some
potential information so the goal of the
protein inference step is to generate a
minimal list of proteins that represents
an entire collection of the peptides
that are detected here what I have is a
two common protein inference situations
these are relatively straightforward but
there are several other situations that
can cause differences in how proteins
can be assigned based on the observed
peptides and in the top case here we see
three unique peptides
that's one four and five and from from
just this information here we know that
protein a and protein B exist in the
sample because protein a can be defined
by peptides one two and three and
protein B is defined from two three four
and five and and these are called
at distinguishable proteins because they
are because they're identified by non i
dint know night entacle peptide sets
however you have the second scenario
where you have peptides six seven eight
nine and they can be matched to both
protein c and d so it's hard to tell if
protein c or protein d or both exist
within the sample so these are reported
as an indistinguishable group to do i
they're they're inferred as an
indistinguishable group because you
don't know if again like i said
protein c or protein d or both proteins
exist and if we had ignored shared
peptides we could have lost information
about protein c and protein d so why
does protein degeneracy occur in shotgun
proteomics the first major source of
peptide degeneracy is the underlying
genomic structure of organisms higher
eukaryote organisms have a more
complicated genomes and they have
modifications like RNA editing and
alternate splicing and post
translational modifications that can
yield similar protein products so if you
because of these similar protein
products a peptide can be matched to
several proteins and the second source
of of peptide degeneracy is the choice
of the protein search databases that are
used in peptide identification and i've
showed you in a couple of slides back
how peptide how proteins search
databases are actually used for peptide
and identification so and there are
several protein search databases like
ncbi uniprot ensemble that greatly
differ in number of protein counts so
that could lead to differences in
peptide identifications and could
possibly lead to peptide degeneracy so
the objective of my
pozole is that high levels of degenerate
peptides may confound basic protein
inference logic and also may cause
complications in when you're quantifying
proteins one strategy that is used in
quantifying proteins is to discard all
the shared peptides and use only unique
peptides however like I showed you
earlier that could cause loss of
information and so what I am proposing
here is an implementation and evaluation
of clustering algorithm that groups
proteins with unique peptide evidence
but large shared peptide evidence to
improve protein identification and
quantification and in the process I will
contrast our protein clustering to
standard protein inference to understand
the effects of protein search databases
and the genomic complexity of the
organisms I'd love to like to understand
if there is any kind of a biological
relevance of the members of the protein
clusters that are generated by this
algorithm so before I move on to my
specific aims I'd like to reiterate some
definitions that i'm i'll be using
throughout my presentation you have
distinguishable proteins like i
mentioned earlier there are proteins
that are represented by sets of non
identical peptides and indistinguishable
proteins are protein groups that are
represented by sets of identified
entacle peptides and shared peptides are
peptides that can be linked to multiple
proteins while unique peptides are only
specific to proteins or protein groups
to one to one protein or protein group
so the first aim aim 1a is to analyze
protein search databases for protein and
peptide degeneracy as i mentioned
earlier there are several sources of
protein search databases that are
commonly used in proteomics studies you
have uniprot or ipi that are used for
higher eukaryotic organisms such as
humans and yeast and ncbi has a highly
curated database with a wide range of
organisms and then ensembl is also used
as a reference genome in
transcriptomics but they also have a
protein versions so what I plan to do is
to compare protein and peptide
characteristics across these multiple
protein sequence databases such as
uniprot ncbi ensembl and ipi and i would
also want to contrast protein and
peptide degeneracies between higher
eukaryotic organisms such as humans and
mice and lower eukaryotes on such as
yeast and i have some preliminary
results from an analysis of four protein
search databases for for human and yeast
and as you can see in this figure here
this is a human protein counts across
four different databases there is
definitely differences across the four
different databases you know you have
uniprot that has about one hundred and
thirty three thousand human protein
counts while ncbi only has about half of
its m 73,000 and in addition we've also
done some theoretical trypsin digestion
of all the proteins and computed the
shared peptide statuses and the red
boxes that you see here for a human
these are the shared peptide
characteristics in all the proteins and
as you can see across databases there is
about thirty at least an average 25
person shared peptides so that sort of
tells us the the complexity of the
genome in in entire eukaryote organisms
or humans and the sort of share pipette
is because of the presence of alternate
splicing or splice variants and in
contrast when you look at lower
eukaryotic organisms such as yeast they
have much they're relatively smaller
protein counts compared to humans you
know you only have about six thousand
compared to one hundred and thirty
thousand here but they're so appears to
be some variation in the protein counts
across protein databases with ncbi
having only about 5,800 compared to NC
or compared to uniprot which has about
6,500 but the interesting one is the
shared peptide percentages they
are very small only about 2% on average
across databases compared to humans
which is about 35% so this sort of tells
us that there is a big genomic
complexity difference between humans and
yeast m1b
is to analyze proteomics search results
from different protein databases for
real biological samples actual
biological samples particularly from
higher eukaryotic organisms usually
represent only a small subset of all
possible proteins and there could also
be some processing biases that would
favor soluble proteins and soluble
peptides and there could also be some
proteins that are very low to detect so
there could so the protein and peptide
degeneracies in these sets of proteins
detected in biological samples may not
really mirror the the degeneracy that we
observe in the whole protein databases
so what I plan to use diverse data sets
of published studies of human plasma
cells cultured mouse cells and yeast
whole cell lysates and and the same
protein databases search databases that
are used in aim 1a to generate
identified proteins and peptides within
these samples and I'll use similar
metrics that I used in aim 1a such as
distinguishable and indistinguishable
protein counts and the shared and unique
peptides to see if if actual samples
actually accentuate or mitigate the
complexities in the underlying protein
search databases aim to is the heart and
soul of this project the first part of
aim two is to implement the proteomic
analysis workflow or the pas clustering
algorithm to results in aim 1b and the
protein the protein inference step
produces a protein summary summary
report and a peptide summary report the
protein summary report lists all the the
proteins that are identify
within a sample and there is also
additional information for each protein
such as the spectral counts for each
protein and also any all the proteins
that share at least a peptide with that
protein and similarly with the peptide
summary report and you generate all the
peptides that you've identified in the
sample and all the spectral counts for
each peptide and also any proteins
within the sample that share that
peptide and the protein and peptide
summary reports the pall clustering
algorithm is then implemented which
performs a pairwise comparison of the
sets of proteins that share at least a
peptide to test for a clustering and
based on shared and unique peptide
evidence proteins may be collapsed into
clusters so there are three ways of
clustering this is a pseudo redundant
cluster in suden pseudo redundant
clustering if two proteins have a very
small unique peptide evidence but they
have but they share a significantly
large shared peptide evidence then these
proteins can be clustered together as a
pseudo redundant clusters and the logic
behind that is if the shared peptide
evidence had not existed then these two
proteins would have been completely
indistinguishable proteins the second
way of clustering is looking for pseudo
subset clusters in pseudo subset
clusters if one protein has a very small
unique peptide evidence but the second
protein has significantly large unique
peptide evidence but they both share
significantly large shared peptide
evidence then these then the first
protein would be a pseudo subset of the
second protein and again the logic
behind that is if the first protein did
not have this unique peptide evidence
then the first protein would have been a
complete subset of these of the second
protein and only the second protein
would happen reported in the protein
inference report and finally the shared
respect clustering by shared spectral
clusters and this is very similar to
pseudo redundant cluster
and this is a method to identify
slightly distant pair of proteins that
can still be collapsed into a cluster
and whenever a pair of proteins are
clustered they're combined into a single
entry and the unique and shared peptide
peptides are recomputed and this
clustering iteration continues till a
stable number of proteins are obtained
so we will evaluate the effects of
clustering by processing the results of
aim 1b with the PAR clustering algorithm
that i just mentioned and throughout
this process this sample that we're
using is exactly the same and the sample
has a definite number of proteins but
what's changing is the the protein
search database that we're choosing and
and the number of identified proteins
must not be dependent on the protein
search database so what we wanted to see
if the clustering algorithm generates
these proteins and peptides catechist
--tx that are more independent of
protein search databases and so for each
protein search database we will obtain a
similar metrics as an aim 1b such as a
distinguishable and indistinguishable
protein counts and shared and unique
peptide counts so let me show you an
example of how poor clustering works
let's say we've identified three
proteins protein a b and c and their
respective peptides after the protein
inference step the black colored
peptides that you see are the unique
peptides so they are only specific to
that protein so for instance protein a
has four black peptides and protein B
has one black peptide and protein cell
has one black peptide and the red
coloured peptide that you see is common
among all three proteins and the blue
colored peptides are only shared between
protein B and protein C so that's how
let's say we've identified these
proteins and so what we're going to do
is implement a pore clustering algorithm
so like I said earlier the pore
clustering algorithm performs a pairwise
testing to see if a clustering can occur
so it's going to compare protein a and
protein B protein a and
in C and protein B and protein C and
after the clustering algorithm what we
notice is that protein a is unchanged
but protein B and protein C are
clustered together as a protein B C
family because they have a significant
shared peptide evidence all the
blue-colored
peptides but they only have a very
unique or a very small number of unique
peptides and once these two porta
proteins are clustered together the
unique and shared peptides are
recomputed for this for this cluster and
when you recompute the unique peptides
what you see is that the the the the
unique proteins that you've seen in
protein B and protein C still exist but
the eight shared peptides the ones in
the blue are now considered unique with
respect to the BC family so that's how
the unique and shape type statuses
change or so the unique peptides axis
change upon the clustering so the part
clustering algorithm is in a way a very
straightforward extension of the protein
inference process we also wanted to look
at clustering algorithms that are in the
literature and compare the poor
clustering with the one in the
literature but to our surprise we only
found two other clustering algorithms
one was by the makers of one was an
actual publication by the makers of
mascot and another one was just a
software technical manual by scaffold
and mascot uses the unique peptide ions
course and and uses that as a distance
metric for hierarchical clustering but
scaffold uses shared peptide evidence
between two proteins two clusters so
what we thought was actually to
implement a similar version of scaffold
and implement that into our palace
during fair framework so we could use
the same protein and peptide summary
reports and another reason would be that
if there's any differences that we see
between the two clustering algorithms
the scaffold and the pas it would only
be because of the clustering algorithm
and not some upstream processing
pipeline so so the scaffold algorithm
also performs a pairwise comparison of
protein
and the cluster's proteins based on
shared peptide evidence so two proteins
are clustered in scaffold two proteins
are clustered if they share at least 50%
of their peptides it's a very simple
straightforward clustering algorithm
compared to PAH and some interesting
things that we can do is look at the are
compared the paw and scaffold clustering
results by looking at the the peptide
and protein characteristics between the
two clustering algorithms we could also
look at the number of clusters that are
generated by the two algorithms and also
some you know may be differences in the
cluster sizes between the between the
two clustering algorithms and some other
interesting things to look at would be
see if there are any common clusters
that are generated by the two clustering
algorithms or any unique ones that are
specific to a single clustering
algorithm so now that I have established
a protein clustering algorithm in this
aim I wanted to see if there is any kind
of a biological relevance to the
clusters that are generated from this
algorithm and what we wanted to do is to
actually perform some internal and
external evaluation of the clusters of
better that are generated from this
algorithm so for the internal evaluation
I wanna Kalki Kalki late the sequence
similarity score offer each pair of
proteins that are in the cluster and the
sequence similarity score will be used
as a distance metric for internal
evaluation metrics such as silhouette
width and what silhouette with measures
is how similar an object or in this case
a protein is to its own cluster compared
to other clusters so what I can do is I
can calculate the average silhouette
with score for all the proteins in the
cluster to determine how tightly the the
clusters are grouped and I will also
research other multiplying on looking at
other cluster metrics such as a maximum
cluster distance and the minimum cluster
distance using sequence similarity score
again between a pair of proteins to see
which can be applied to this problem and
also see if the results actually differ
significantly between the poor
clustering algorithm and the and the
scaffold clustering algorithm
so for truly evaluating an algorithm we
need an external method of evaluation
and unfortunately in our situation we
don't have a gold standard for
evaluating or clustering algorithm so
we'll have so what we plan to use is
some biological information about the
about the cluster members to give some
kind of sense of how well the clustering
algorithm performs so in addition to
sequence similarity scores we also
wanted to look at some external
information regarding the proteins such
as the gene ontology terms to see if our
clustering has some kind of a biological
meaning to it so we wanted to use
molecular function and biological
process ontology x' to identify any
significantly shared geo terms for the
protein members in a cluster and usually
the geo terms provides you with the
value for clusters based on the the
background set based on the the
occurrence of common geo terms on the
background distribution and for the
background distribution for the
background set of proteins what we
wanted to do is to actually use the
proteins that are obtained all the
proteins that are obtained from the the
protein inference step so the last aim
is to understand the effects of
clustering and also the protein search
databases on quantitative information
and for this I plan to use TMT labelled
Mouse samples the TMT is tandem mass tag
and that and obtain quantitative
information on all unique peptide
spectrum matches using the proteome
discover software and the proteome
discourage software provides you with
quantitative or provides you with
intensities or and the quantitative data
and from this quantitative information I
can compute the quantity quantifiable
information content or qia which is just
a ratio of unique PSMs out of the total
number of identified Pearson's PSM is
again like I said earlier it's a peptide
to spectral match and what we wanted to
see is how the quantitative results
change upon clustering and also across
multiple protein databases and we wanted
to see if there are any differences in
qia across protein databases and also
before-and-after clustering so what we
expect is that there will be a greatest
change in qia for highly abundant
homologous protein families such as
Acton's
or turbulence or immunoglobin circa
keratins which would have a large number
of shared peptide evidence but a very
small number of unique peptide evidence
so when you apply protein clustering to
those samples they would they would form
a family and all the shared peptide
evidence would then be unique peptide
evidence with respect to those families
and by doing that it actually increases
the quantifiable information which is
just the account of unique peptides the
count that you get from unique peptides
so let me walk you through again an
example of how qyc could be computed and
I'll use the same example that I've
showed you previously and just to recall
you know the black peptides are the
unique peptides and the and the red ones
are common among all three proteins and
the blue ones are just shared between
protein B and protein C and when there
is no protein clustering qyc is computed
right after protein inference and qia
like I said is the total unique PSMs
over the total identified PSMs and in
this case the total number of unique
PSMs are just the the peptide or unique
peptide counts is 6 you have 4 from
protein a 1 from protein B and 1 from
protein C and the total identified PSMs
is 15 which is the account of all the
peptides so the QI C is 6 over 15 now
when you implement protein clustering
you implement like I showed you earlier
protein questioning was implemented and
you've come up with protein a and a
protein B C family and now the total
unique PSMs is still 6 but then these
eight peptides the shaper pets are now
unique with respect to the family so
then they get added to the unique PSM
counts you get through 14 and the total
identified PSS is still 15 so the ratio
is 14 out of 15 this is a simple example
where we show how protein clustering
actually improves quantitative
information
in conclusion today I have proposed
implementing and testing protein
clustering algorithms that combine
proteins with significant shade peptide
evidence and very small unique peptide
evidence and in the process I plan on
investigating the effects of protein
search databases and also investigate
the effects of the genomic complexity
between higher eukaryotic organisms and
lower eukaryotic origins organisms and I
will compare the pore clustering
algorithm with the scaffold and look at
some internal and external evaluation
metrics and also finally I would want to
see if they're comparing the effects of
protein clustering on quantitative
results so look at any qia differences
before and after clustering and also
across databases and finally I'd like to
thank dr. Aaron Cohen
dr. Phil Marth and dr. airy broad for
their support and their guidance on this
project and additionally I'd like to
thank dr. Shannon McWeeny Diane dr.
Lynne Schwab and all my BCB classmates
and professors thank you questions yes
no so the the the protein counts we got
these from the non redundant databases
these are straight from where the
protein search databases or direct
counts but the the peptides were we
performed this pythonic way of trypsin
digestion where you just cleave the
sequences between arginine and lysine KN
R and we just look at the shape applied
counts or sorry the peptide counts
yiii these are these are proteins
straight from the the databases so I I
guess they could be different but I get
the point of this what I'm planning on
showing here is the the differences in
the in the in the higher eukaryotic
organism compared to lower you carried
organism and and because we're using
straight up results from protein search
databases I haven't actually thought
about if you need to compare similar
proteins this is because the in this aim
what we're trying to show is you know
how protein search databases differ that
would be a hard question it depends on
what type of research that you're
shooting for if you wanted to get all
the information about your sample then
perhaps using a larger database would be
good but again the caveat is that larger
databases could have too much
information where you know the shared
peptide evidence would be abnormal and
in those kind of situations you probably
want to use this kind of algorithm so
it's I'm not I'm not I think I think by
the end of the project perhaps or to
have an idea on on the better protein
search database but for now I wouldn't
know if or I wouldn't want to say if I
want if I'm actually preaching for us
specific protein search database yeah
these you say using almost a thousand
right are those six thousand represent
in the human and if not like how how do
we compare the two it's kind of playing
on the same see but like the problem
would be that there are these parties
that it looks like people with a small
compartment is that each compartment is
in there or they independent don't even
how do you clean that up
okay so these are called non redundant
databases what by that what they mean is
there's only a single entry of the
entire sequence
so all these six thousand six sixty five
that you see for uniprot they're all
different sequences and we've actually
I'm not I'm not showing you another
little part where we've actually looked
at you're actually tested to see if the
non redundant databases are actually non
redundant meaning that they don't have
any duplicate sequences what we did
notice was that there're about you know
there was a small percentage of proteins
or or sequences that are actually
duplicated but to get back to your
question like I said these are non
redundant data so there's only one copy
or one sequence for each protein and if
you're if they in their database they
they show certain protein having two
different sequences then that would be
represented in these graphs also but
usually if there if there are two
proteins there I'm assuming they would
be two different sequences there they
wouldn't have the same exact sequence of
two different proteins in the in the
database
alcohol dehydrogenase right you and I
have that it is my protein and I know
there's difference in perfect in both is
represented to some degree in the
eSports vice versa or is there like
should we do some sort of filters a
piece of the pro to their common which
would be more similar comparisons and
have their own different difference I
was actually looking at straight-up
protein all the protein sequences from
these non redundant data bases and doing
a straight up count of how these numbers
change across databases if you want to
know what's a sample based on where it
came from
is a large database from that organism
where you're asking is interesting it's
a different question
okay so when you're trying to
distinguish the proteins the redundancy
degeneracy is good firstly between the
peptide degeneracy within an organist
across across the database to that of
Argos there's also complications
generous across organs happens and
things like that but that's the next
order of activity
other question
this weekend in Britain